hey flash fam is Charlie this is going
to be my midseason finale video so much
craziness so many comic book Easter eggs
so much mythology so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway going on now - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video make
sure you enable alerts so you don't miss
anything during the off season but I'll
talk more about what's going to be
happening during the break at the end of
the video they're just so much craziness
in this episode is that your true
mid-season finale they just try to crank
up as much mythology as much big action
and heart as they could so there were a
lot of like really touching Christmasy
moments so let's do top 10 WTF and then
I'll add a bunch of extra this should be
like 15 or 20 just because there was so
much stuff in this episode but number 10
Julianne Talbert flashback to India they
tell the story of how he found the
philosopher's stone but then they're
slowly setting up the twist where they
explained the dual personality which is
right out of the comics so number 9 he
finds the philosopher's stone
but when Barry throws him in the prison
he has no idea what's going on but then
Barry reveals his identity and he
explains his backstory in much greater
detail so the thing here there's so many
Easter eggs the paper that he wrote in
college about the Philosopher's Stone
was written by Albert Desmond who is the
name of dr. alchemy in the comics but
Julian Albert is his name on the TV show
so Julian explains that his sister
passed away but then he saw a vision of
her the way that Cisco has been seeing
Dante in the episode telling him where
to find the Philosopher's Stone how to
bring her back but then we learned
secretly number 8 is just Sabbat are
speaking to them from the speedforce
trying to get out open it and we can be
together again open the box so they
don't really explain exactly how it is
that saboteur can manifest this way but
it's almost in the way that the Speed
Force wormhole aliens last season
appeared to Barry as people that he
cared about so number 7 Jay Garrick's
Speed Force explainer I'm actually going
to turn this into another video tomorrow
into like a much bigger video because it
was really cool the way they included
this mythology he says it's an endless
void of energy time and space which is
house avatar is X
arian Singh the future the past the
present how he knows so much about them
but just like the comics he's stuck in
there so number six the comic book
version of this is that Wally West was
the first person to Fights avatar they
changed a little bit of his backstory
for the TV show they're turning him more
into like an ancient person like
apocalypse in the x-men comics like
somebody who existed a long long time
ago instead of comic books avatar who
was a cold war pilot till he was struck
with the bolt of lightning and became
super fast but he still didn't use the
Speed Force in the comics so I'll
explain that in a second because
savatage powers in the comics are a
little bit different from what the TV
shows doing with them but what happened
in the comics is that Wally West was
able to defeats avatar by taking him
into the Speed Force a place that he
couldn't get to ended up getting trapped
there so it became a prison for him
until the first flash rebirth the Geoff
Johns wrote way way back wheres avatar
emerges from the Speed Force but it was
really only a cameo so like he comes out
of the Speed Force in the reverse flash
has this secret plot where he's poison
Barry with the negative Speed Force that
makes him kill any other speedsters that
he touches it's sort of like poisoning
the Speed Force well so saboteur dies
and that's the last you see of him so
they taken that part of sabotage story
turned it into a Hindu myth about him
gaining powers via the Philosopher's
Stone and then turning into this Speed
God that number five gets trapped in the
Speed Force by a future version of Barry
like he says I am the future flash so
everyone was like does he talking about
the future flash from the new 52 comics
no he just saying that he is the future
of what speedsters are what they will
become thus avatar flashbacks oh that
was so cool so the human forms avatar
that you're seeing here is supposed to
be Daniel Cudmore who most of you know
is Colossus from the older Bryan Singer
x-men films he didn't play Colossus
during Deadpool but it just shows how he
got his powers from the Philosopher's
Stone and then became the form that he
is now so who knows if we'll ever see
human forms avatar again but we actually
never learned his real name in the
comics we only knew him as
avatar they never revealed what his name
was before he gave himself that name
like he named himself Savitt are the
Hindu god of motion so you can see why
the TV show chose to make it a Hindu
mythological thing that wasn't in the
comics likes avatar just picked that
name for himself but his power so the TV
show kind of showed that he derives his
powers from the Stone not from the Speed
Force in the way Barry does that's also
kind of a comic book thing where he can
move really fast he's a speedster but he
doesn't touch the Speed Force like Barry
or Wally West does so there was this big
thing about sharing giving taking Speed
Force transferring it between people so
that's what's avatar did he just stole
speed from other people he couldn't take
it directly from the source like Wally
West could so what he would do is he
would just like take everyone's speed so
like Jesse quick loses all her speed but
because of Wally's direct connection to
the Speed Force he's not able to take
his speed the same way so if that sounds
confusing don't worry it just means that
because he doesn't have the direct
connection to the Speed Force that's why
he can't leave the Speed Force prison on
his own he needs another speedster to
let him out so number four Cisco drinks
the kool-aid I love this scene because
it's kind of a reverse of what happened
during the killer frost episode Caitlin
has to rescue Cisco from himself the
same way Cisco did for her so it was a
really touching moment and I actually
thought that she was going to have to
use her powers on him but he was totally
ready to vibe her ass right out of the
room like that look on his face is just
so intense but speaking of which number
three Julianne Albert confirmed as dr.
alchemy finally when they take the mask
off but then they explained the twist in
order to get him to trust him Barry has
to reveal his identity and then through
the course of the episode he comes
around he has Christmas with them
meaning the Julianne is now officially
on Team flash so you can just look
forward to more scenes with him working
at STAR Labs and then number two
speaking of working together Jay Garrick
flash team-up I love the flash versus
avatar scene so you have Jay Garrick
flash versus avatar that was brutal then
you have Wally and Barry versus avatar
just that crazy scene of why
Berry just getting jumped around the
room on the monitor because they can't
see Savitt our but then while it gets
thinner and he can but they did say
there's going to be a whole lot more Jay
Garrick team ups in the back half of the
season so we'll see him working with
Barry a lot more but number one WTF
Barry gets kicked into the future when
they tried to throw the philosopher's
stone back into the speedforce it has to
watch iris die so there been a number of
versions of the flash that have had to
watch evil speedsters of one kind or
another hurt the people they love
just been forced to watch it and then
try to fix it later so I feel like there
are a couple big reactions that people
have the scenes like this where you know
one they just flat-out don't believe it
like okay they're not gonna kill Candice
Patton off the show they'll fix it
somehow but this is they're ticking
clock like there's no way that Barry is
totally gonna chill on this I know they
ended on a very hopeful moment there in
their new apartment together but this
is going to bug the hell out of
Barry for the rest of the season like
they said five months in the future
that's basically the season finale so
it's like saying this is going to be
their finale but there's so much other
stuff in this episode like when it gets
kicked to the future
there's Infantino street that's Carmine
Infantino just a big comic book creator
then i almost forgot you know tied for
first Mark Hamill as trickster of Earth
three totally dressed as the Joker Joker
in everything but name he was a very
small presence just because he's so busy
filming the Star Wars movies right now
but I'm so happy that they brought him
back on and he was just so much more
vicious than previous versions of the
trickster he just looks like he has so
much fun when he gets to play that
character so I would expect that to
happen every single year where he comes
back for at least one episode but I
would expect because they can use Julian
now as a telephone for speaking dis
avatar that they'll do that again in the
future but he's going to come back to
haunt them they'll have to be some twist
where the alchemists stone finds its way
into somebody else's hands otherwise
there'll be no way force avatar to get
back into the real world to kill iris in
five months
so as crazy as all that is I really love
the moment where team flash gives Wally
his suit so for all of you who felt like
they've dragged on this Wally plot for
too long he's finally going to start
doing Kid Flash stuff so he'll have a
lot of fun when Jesse quick comes back
for those of you asking
know exactly which episode it's going to
be but it's going to be sometime early
in the back half of the season there'll
be a whole bunch of flash family stuff
in yes there will be a gorilla grodd
episode there were some pictures from
the set so if you guys want me to do a
video on the accelerated man just let me
know in the comments there's going to be
a whole bunch of bonus flash videos
during the break so don't worry
make sure you have alerts enabled so you
get everything but let me know in the
comments what you want me to do videos
about while we wait for it to come back
that's going to be January 24th so I
know that sounds like a long time but
it's actually not that long so what I'm
gonna do if they don't drop a trailer
for the next episode I'm gonna drop a
speedforce
Prison sabot our explainer video in the
morning before I do my arrow mid-season
finale video so speaking of trailer a
lot of you are asking about the
spider-man Home Coming trailer that was
supposed to drop so it turns out like
the people that made this whatever came
out and said no this is totally fake
even though it looks official so if we
get a spider-man homecoming trailer
it'll probably drop with rogue one
otherwise I'm expecting the Super Bowl
but if we learn anything I'll post a
video that was supposed to be a special
agents of shield post-credits teaser
that was like something super special so
whatever that is I'll totally do a video
for it but let me know what you guys
think of the midseason finale I do love
the holiday episodes when they work
really well like they did a little bit
of holiday stuff like you see Kaitlin
use her killer frost powers to turn it
into a white Christmas it ends on a
really hopeful warm note despite the
fact that you know that there's a
ticking clock now five months in the
future iris is totally gonna get it with
a steel spike right through the stomach
unless they do something to stop him so
you can expect all kinds of very
craziness trying to figure out how to do
that but I'll talk about this a little
bit more in my flash video tomorrow
but he's going to have to deepen his
connection to the Speed Force in a way
that he hasn't done before like in the
way Luke Skywalker becomes much more
powerful as he learns more about the
force the light side in the dark side so
good hide in the flash ring giveaway is
still going to be going on week to week
during the break so no worries about
that either while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for the arrow
trailer for tomorrow's episode and you
can click here for all my other flash
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys
I